the men and women that I've worked with
the ones that are born directors they're
just can't imagine them doing anything
else you know they they oh you know they
never make you feel like that they never
make you feel like they don't have
they're not steering the ship so to
speak you know and right and then you
feel totally like part of the crew and
like okay let's go I'm with you 100 you
know and then you I show up in the
morning I'm always on time I'm always
prepared I mean we've worked
together you know what I'm like I'm open
and yeah ready and and you know whatever
you guys want to do is okay with me you
know but when I was younger I had a lot
less tolerance about this situation that
I'm talking about about not feeling like
I'm in the right position that the
people that are supposed to be in charge
are not do are not talented and that's
uh that when I was a kid that used to
make me I used to get worried and I
would I would start to try to take over
luckily my career has gone is is very
much under my own control and there's
been good things about that and bad
things about it but it is under my own
control